hier squeeze aujourd'hui on se retrouve
sur turbo 10 moan qui est un simulateur
de crash vous l'avez aussi conseillé en
masse et je me suis dit bon on va y
faire un petit pas un c'est parti
premier petit fait j'ai tenté de lui
mettre un visage
j'essaie plein d'imagés ça n'a pas
marché donc cet homme s'appelle
désormais monsieur point d'interrogation
bref la pause regarde mes fesses up
plaque d'huile
tu as la chute naze mais c'était naze 1
voilà cache pas le visage
on veut plus te voir on veut plus ou
alors tu nous offre une glace il sait
qu'un bon prix pour une star donc cet
homme n'atteint pas les pédales je ne
sais pas comment on conduit à faire ou
alors la pause what they say say say
m'appelle hausse ça c'est la pause je
fais des trucs avec levier de vitesses à
mon dieu mon dieu et la position couche
ah bah voilà avec qui va vite c'est ça
qu'on veut attendre un peu il peut se
tenir autrement que comme ça sur ce vélo
oui
par contre dans la lah non non non
bon ok j'ai peut-être dû mettre un truc
pour nous faire accélérer attention
revient ici vélo ah voilà c'est ça qu'on
veut un jeu crainte bien attention oui
et c'est le salto arrière
oui maman oui j'arrive à l'école je suis
en route ça le faisait dans donc james
bond
elle pose est passé sur la voiture mais
pas du tout ce personnage a carrément la
tremblote créé sa boîte c'est quoi ce
niveau mondial tombé cuma prendre un
skateboard
alors attendez à qui cela était sûr à
huy boeing bien sûr
oh oui on va mettre la pause voilà la
pause
qu'est ce que je fous là oh oui à fond
[ __ ] attention très bien d'accord donc
c'était voir mon nul en 6 7 positions
improbables voici un dérivé de la
position foetale appelé la position
scoliose ma jambe à jambes
le pneu qui nous vole carrément d'autres
gens qu est-ce qui pensaient partir en
courant avec une seule jambe non c'était
techniquement pas possible là bien sûr
que ça possible c'est la fraction de
seconde on ne peut croire que ce vannes
à une jambe
voilà c'est quoi les pauses et ça ok
bronzer sur un caddie là on le sait pas
mais ça en fin de journée c'est les
vertèbres et la colonne cassé en deux un
hockey en plus on y va avec pas mal de
vitesse donc ses pieds finalement fonds
guise de pendentif
je ne sais pas attention c'est un beau
jeu tout simple mais c'est pas du tout
raciste mais oui tu as raison soutient
toile dos avec les pieds oui voilà ok ça
sera plus doux en l'air c'est quoi ce
encore mais arrêtez l'oiseau aller au
niveau des oiseaux de là on peut croire
que c'est un sumo et de la une
prostituée c'est carrément visa ouais le
tragique destin d'un oiseau et alk
abello d'harry fait je veux cet oiseau
allez salut up qui se grattent les
fesses vite fait contre camion c'est
quoi ça on n'a pas essayé encore je
suppose qu'il peut il peut encore se
mettre en mode
ah mais non mais là c'est la nuque qui
se cassent la jeune homme what makes
aloses le truc est allé méga ou quoi ni
par vraiment le truc à le bien la
lumière invisible avec des choeurs
pardon excuse-moi sk ce mois en tombant
très bien je veux cette voiture tout de
suite mais pourquoi mais qui fait ce à
quoi est ce qui nettoyait son capot et
que d'un coup ne sais pas pourquoi la
voiture à des parents et qu'il était
comme ça regardez moi c'est fait ce
qu'on veut dire des paquets dessus à
d'un bouton sur la fesse gauche aller
non pour passer sable ou là le pantin
désarticulé
il va se détend well as i lay c'était
clairement mon gars pération et
développeurs c'était naze
c'était mes gars nasa tel point qui dort
encore sa part avait alors déjà je te
permets pas de te gratter à cet endroit
là vous en promettant il a atterri dans
une pose high kick c'est divin moi ça me
tiendrais pas quand je marche chez moi
comme ça qu'à un moment il se passe ce à
quoi d'innocence
le petit qui fait du vélo de manière
bizarre soit maman je revienne de
boulangerie aussi aux le mec cette
chance de ouf monter les mm non mais
c'est quoi les douces à la porte j'ai
beau gars mais toi vous avez joué au
loto joie joie tout ce que tu veux mais
tu gagneras tu gagneras sauf si tu fais
cette position vraiment ridicule la tête
et voilà maintenant on obtient un b
l'arrosoir je voulais photo d'arrosoir à
côté voilà leur ressemblance est
flagrante aux yeux pour un montant 10
pounds complice lui a pas encore touché
les voitures très bien mais les voitures
elles se prêtent pas ils en ont rien à
[ __ ] sa part en travers mon tunnel
howald toit en vol mais non mes mecs
mais c'est le cas le 4 4 a pris car vend
plus cher que mon propre perso je sais
qu'il n'arrivera patins à roues mais on
sait jamais peut-être que un petit
miracle par ci par là
ah non clairement pas clairement pas
mais elle même le khadim troll voilà ils
montent dessus allez facile
bon j'ai corser un peu le truc la petite
flaque d'huile le so what
est ce qu'un enfant de trois ans et demi
peut battre cette voiture non mais
serait carrément arriver avant que même
qu'on attend du premier boost et je suis
tellement triste si je n'ai pas d'avis
s'allumer sur le bus
ce n'est pas parce que tu n'as pas de
pénis que tu dois faire semblant d'en
avoir un avec ton pied c'est scandaleux
c'est ça qu'on va monsieur van allez-y
monsieur levade hommes et non monsieur
le bol pour le monsieur monsieur vous
êtes désormais une décapotable
ouais comme ça hop il croit qu'il s'en
sort le petit rabat et veufs c'est
l'heure des bus les enfants allez je
vous avais tous à l'école ya au plat
c'est la moto tu veux mon taux désormais
la date
oui au tas ce camion fait de la
gymnastique attendait donc life un petit
gang gamme style pendant qu'il est en
train de faire complètement défoncée par
un camion
la moto d'agent secret elle roule sur
l'arbre pour finalement atterri sur le
béton et ceux qui arrêtent rocky banc
contre le poteau j'y crois pas et le qui
fait un seul taux pendant ce temps là y
ait ou une fois un petit show là il nous
fait même coucou
oh oh oh oui oh ils croient nagé pendant
quelques instants dans l'air puis il est
très très vite rade à la réalité par cet
incroyable camion ben bon bah voilà
j'espère cette petite vidéo sur turbo
disponible en aura plus vous la caisse
fait que samassa haut comme suit
vigneault il voudrait en voir aussi aux
le j'aimerais bien le prendre
l'âge où je venais je vais prendre à
genève
[Musique]